Congratulations by the way again you
[__]
you know David Goggins
suck it
yeah some dude I was surfing yesterday
and some dude in the water
after surfing beside me for like 45
minutes he was like yo Cody by the way I
appreciate you going Goggins mode
brother
like damn yeah that's why I did it man
you had to go Goggins had to Goggins
mode for a second you should have hit
him right there dude you [__] with
Goggins
gogging some big ass dick on the [__]
wave [__]
he's like cool man I was trying to give
you a compliment you're like yeah bad
timing yeah get owned
I'm sure you go Goggins mode all the
time
[Laughter]
yeah so right after the race finished oh
actually I did have I did try to have I
did try to choke down a nasty little
tree right after
okay the the problem is like when I when
I do these things
um I have this weird like fight or
flight sort of like anxiety that happens
at the end I think most people finish a
race and they're like ah their body goes
into like recovery relaxation mode where
it's like it's over right I just stay in
horrible like I'm in pain this is Hell
mode even after I'm done so I was
sitting there I wasn't running anymore
for two hours afterwards my this muscle
cramped right here I yawned and my whole
face cramped I couldn't oh I could move
my jaw I was just saying
and I just felt sick and like just I
just I can't even explain it it's just
pure just the worst feeling ever even
after I'm done for two hours sitting
there so then my dad finishes and we go
to the bar
there's like a bar you can see the
finish line from so we're just gonna
chill there until
and then so he's like do you want a beer
and I was like yeah sure I'll try and
like that was my first little nasty
little treat right right I could choke
down a little nasty little beer right
now right
yeah slide me a sudsy one
yeah I felt like a little [__] for some
beer yeah you're like give me that foam
give it to me yes exactly so he got he I
see him at the bar he's ordering the
beers and then he turns around and he's
holding two Guinness
oh
no
I was like
really he walks over I'm like really
he's like what
damn you're dead hold on first of all
let's give your dad a little let's give
this man ultimate props he does not do
anything on five no no he doesn't that
dude just did an Iron Man and he's like
okay dude you want beer now we're not
drinking piss you said beer we're
drinking thickest hardest to drink beer
on planet Earth I don't [__] up now
yeah
you said beer yeah and it's just bitter
you know yeah dude
like it's just it all it is is bitter
normally I like it so he was like of
course I thought you liked dark beer and
I was like yeah but I just oh man for 13
hours straight all I've been picturing
is like a light crispy [__] Bud Light
Lime damn dude your dad just low-key
calling you a [__] no he did
he did he's like that's that's crazy
yeah yeah he's like oh all right uh you
just go you want you want Goggins mode
right
I'm sorry man I thought uh sorry I
thought it was sitting with someone in
Goggins mode
really oh sorry yeah can we get some
light beer can we get some uh just a big
jug of pp for the little hoe right here
this
for this [__] pledge right here can
we get some piss and a jug for this
pledge
honestly I probably would have preferred
piss
Ed yeah
all right so you get the Guinness that's
it down in front of me and I'm like I
guess I could try
and I drank like four sips and she's not
really sitting right and
so I'm sitting there
and I left my phone in one of the
transition bags so I don't have my phone
it's nothing like we're just sitting
there right we're killing time before my
mom finishes I feel like [__] it's late
at night
so I'm sitting there and I kind of like
lean up against the wall and I fall
asleep
my Dad's on his phone I think Kelsey's
on her on her phone and I'm just like
kind of leaned up against the pillar
like this like just sleeping all of a
sudden I feel like a massive poke right
here and I'm like ah and I wake up and
it's the security guard and he's like
bro
you can't follow Australian you can't
fall asleep in a venue mate what are you
doing
yeah I was like oh it's [__]
sorry I mean this this venue this venue
this bar was literally 10 feet from the
Finish Line
a massive crowd people are cheering yeah
you can't be a little bit lenient today
at 11 p.m of all [__] right all the
rest of the people in here just finished
the race sorry two things one
I think you were being a little bit
lenient sorry and uh
but two the [__] irony that oh damn
it that's that's another one uh the
irony that after a Iron Man this guy is
the [__] nerve the nerve to call you
out for being tired I know that's I mean
normally I would be like yeah [__]
yeah what am I doing I wasn't even like
I wasn't like normally they say that
[__] because people are drunk and they
fall asleep right I'm wearing metal I
have the metal around my neck it's very
clear that I'm not just [__] up
I'm like I just
finished the [__] race
so I'm like a little bit pissed at this
guy because I'm like yeah sorry but then
I'm like why am I sorry I'm just no one
can see me right now the bar by the way
there was like nobody there
yeah there's like five parties there and
all of them were related to the race
somehow so I'm sure they weren't like oh
we're leaving that guy's sleeping we're
leaving this place
that guy's sleeping so now we're not
gonna spend any money here yeah we're
gonna bounce and go to the other one of
the other 10 bars on this strip right
outside the [__] Finish Line Makari
it's like three points
um what a dick yeah then I'm like okay
he's like you can't you you can't uh I
can't really do an Australian thing
right now but you can't it can't yeah
can't is like I think he called me yeah
[Laughter]
you can't sleep here okay yeah yeah yeah
no yeah yeah
um so then I'm like okay
I'm like a little bit pissed and I'm
sitting there and I'm like okay I'll try
and sip another sip of this beer and
then I'm like fighting the sleep and the
beer's not sitting right and all of a
sudden I'm like oh I gotta I gotta go to
the bathroom and I run to them oh that's
a stupid chill you ran after running I
ran it I like I sort of like limp jogged
over to the bathroom because I had to
get there oh man it was not sitting
right you know you get that feeling
start salivating like crazy yeah dude
why does your body do that why does your
body do that I don't know it's so funny
your mouth just gets so wet and you're
like yeah dude coming in five seconds no
matter where
so I like limp Sprint over to the
bathroom and there's one stall like the
bathroom is probably
like uh it's probably like a [__] I
don't know
15 square foot like rectangle right one
you walk in there's a stall one stall
with the door closed and it's locked
somebody's in there and then there's on
the left there's a trough urinal and
then there's two sinks and a trap a tiny
little trash can in between the sinks no
no is this like a proper like like a
structure are we talking about like uh
like a trailer bathroom no it's a proper
structure but like the inside of this
place was sort of like a dive bar so you
imagine like got it got it okay okay and
used for years and years and it's only
Queen yeah I just I just want to make
sure we have all the details and
possible sense so that if anyone is
exercising or enjoying themselves right
now I want them to be as repulsed as
possible going into what I think is
coming after this so all right and the
dude in the stall had just finished the
races so he was taking care of some
business in there
he was making some serious Sense on his
own yeah it did kind of look like that
honestly Luke
but if that's the urinal like the trough
went down to the ground and the sinks
both kind of looked like that
and there was a little Trash Can you
know like a one gallon trash can between
the two sinks right well R2D2 one of
these little [__] yeah yeah so I'm
like I'm looking around I'm like I can't
puke in the urinal so I just take that
little trash can and I just start
booting like just Brown beer and then
like bile and just like I'm like like
making so much noise
and all of a sudden
like I hear the door open in these two
British guys walk in and they're
hammered and the dude like looks at me
with like crossed eyes and he's like
you're all right mate and I'm like yeah
I just I just I just
finished
and I just keep going
and then the dude comes out of the stall
and it's these two guys's friend
and it's also the dude that I was biking
with for like two hours we were like
kind of happy over and over again so he
looks at me he looks at me and he's like
you're good
and I was like yeah
he's like first one first Iron Man I was
like yeah like
I've been there like you're like yeah
yeah
yeah keep in mind like we're all
touching shoulders this room is so small
yeah so then the dudes start peeing they
turn to the left and both of them start
peeing in the trough urinal and I'm
still throwing up right behind them as
they're peeing oh
and the dude is washing his hands and
I'm pissed and I'm throwing up in the it
was so funny and then
so then I I you know I went back to the
table and I felt like a little bit of
Pride that I just puked and you know the
[__] guy that told me to wake up I'm
like yeah I just [__] puked in your
you know your whole bathroom boy smells
like puke now yeah and then you're like
let me get a [__] Guinness [__] yeah
exactly